the web is visual well obviously
otherwise this course wouldn't exist but
not all people surfing the web have the
ability to see images like this one for
the visually impaired screen readers are
essential to make sense of the web this
is links it's an all text browser and
this is what right it looks like on
links without images this is all a user
has to decipher your website and they
usually won't even be reading it they'll
be hearing it through a screen reader
like chromevox the good news is that you
can still make images meaningful by
using all attributes responsibly here
let me show you what I mean I've enabled
chromevox which is a screen reader that
will be reading this page to you here
let's hear what it has to say the
Internet thanks you for being
responsible with your alt tags to
replicate the experience of being
visually impaired I'm giving you some
information using images that don't make
any sense on their own or at all really
don't leave your visually impaired
visitors out in the cold here are some
tips about all tags alt tags should be
descriptive for important images like
this body surfer because body surfing is
important I guess alt tags should be
empty for images that are just
decorations like this boiler image do
you get the joke it's a boiler to
represent boilerplate code which is
sometimes empty of content alt tags
should be set on every image just like
this pig is set on being so darn cute so
there you have it check the instructor
notes if you want to see the tips that
chromevox just read to you oh and by the
way to get chromevox it's just a Chrome
extension so it's really easy to install